you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's program
electric car company tesla hits the
brakes on cryptocurrency
bitcoin because of its climate impact
how farmers could help the environment
and make agriculture
more sustainable
and we meet sammy safari the
award-winning conservationist
saving sea turtles in kenya
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions we aim to take you to the
heart of a climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come now they're one of the biggest
names in the car industry
and last year produced the world's
best-selling electric
vehicle and now tesla says it's not
going to accept
bitcoin as a form of payment according
to the company's chief executive
elon musk it's because of the impact the
cryptocurrency has
on the climate anisha sethi reports
[Applause]
tesla the brainchild of elon musk is a
name synonymous with electric cars
and clean energy in march this year
the company announced it would accept
bitcoin as a form of payments
now a u-turn in a bid to make transport
more sustainable
the ceo has suspended the decision
in a tweet musk said we are concerned
about rapidly increasing use of fossil
fuels for bitcoin
mining and transactions especially coal
which has the worst emissions of any
fuel
cryptocurrency is a good idea on many
levels and we believe it has a promising
future
but this cannot come at great cost to
the environment
analysts see the move as an attempt to
assess concerns about sustainability
there may be some sort of connection to
the change in political winds in the us
but i think this is quite possibly just
about an ongoing debate inside tesla
between a wing of the business that is
totally connected to these this is the
silicon valley mindset
and the other side of the business
that's perhaps more connected to more
responsible shareholders and the more
environmentally friendly focus of the
business
selling electric cars as a replacement
for combustion engines
bitcoin enthusiasts insist mining mainly
involves renewable energy
however it can be an intense activity
that often relies on electricity
generated with fossil fuels
although tesla doesn't plan to sell any
of its bitcoin investment
it hopes to use it for transactions if
mining shifts to more sustainable energy
in future
anisha sethi sky news
well isabel asher hamilton is senior
reporter at insider and joins me now
so how can a virtual currency be energy
intensive
well um it comes down to how these
um bitcoins are mined uh which is done
mostly using hardware so when someone
wants to
mine a bitcoin they have to basically
get
a computer or lots of computers to solve
lots and lots of calculations which is
very energy intensive
but if it's renewable energy that's used
presumably that's
not so much of a problem absolutely if
it was all renewable energy that was
being used
to power these computers that would be
fine but there's lots of
i mean it's studies kind of vary on how
much of the energy being used already is
renewable
but there's quite a few that say that
loads of the energy
is coming from like elon musk in his
tweet
coal and things like that so yes
theoretically if it was all
renewable electricity it would be fine
but that's not the reality
and when you have a big figure like elon
musk making
a statement like this what does that
mean for the future of bitcoin and also
tesla
it's true that elon musk is a bit of a
folk hero almost among sort of
crypto currency enthusiasts and there
was a reaction
um the value of bitcoin did sink a
little bit
when he made this announcement tesla is
a huge company to accept
uh a currency that only recently started
becoming even a tiny bit mainstream
but you know bitcoin has is already
worth so much more than it used to be
worth
and like he said he's not getting rid of
the investment yet so it's really hard
to predict
isabel asha hamilton thank you in
today's other climate news
new research by energy company bulb has
found households in the north of england
are being put off
buying greener vehicles that's because
there are far fewer
charging points compared with the south
bulb wants the government to invest in
more
public charging points to make
low-carbon cars more affordable and
accessible for everyone
microplastic pollution found in rivers
across the uk
is caused by water suppliers data from
researchers at manchester university
suggests companies are releasing
wastewater into slow-moving rivers which
are unable to break up the pieces of
plastic
experts believe microplastics can alter
entire ecosystems
and harm wildlife
[Applause]
john kerry will travel to europe for
climate talks ahead of the cop 26
conference
the white house has confirmed the u.s
climate envoy will visit the uk
italy and germany during his trip which
starts on thursday
it comes after the united states raised
its carbon reduction targets to as much
as
52 percent by 2030
[Applause]
hundreds of people have been given the
opportunity to visit wetlands to improve
their mental health
the wildfowl and wetlands trust and the
mental health foundation
have launched the blue prescribing
scheme which uses nature as a therapy
for anxiety and depression
the six-week course will give people the
chance to stay near wetlands
and take part in activities such as bird
watching and pond dipping
and people on the isle of wight are
making a feathery new resident feel at
home
chief a rare white-tailed sea eagle has
been brought from scotland to live at
robin hill nature park
as part of a reintroduction program
farmers need more help to secure their
livelihoods and help them tackle
climate change and nature loss according
to a new report from the institute for
public policy research
agriculture is responsible for around 10
percent of the uk's greenhouse gas
emissions
but that figure is decreasing and you
can see here the estimated greenhouse
gas emissions for agriculture in the uk
between 1990 and 2018 and emissions for
carbon dioxide
methane and nitrous oxide are all lower
in 2018
that's the blue bars than they were in
1990 which in yellow
and if we look at the total greenhouse
gas emissions for the sector
they've fallen by nearly nine million
tons in that period
but much more needs to be done if the uk
is to reach net zero emissions by
2050. well fraser hugo is a farm
farmer based in north yorkshire and he
joins me now welcome to you
just how important an issue is this for
you are there steps that you've been
able to
to take to ensure that your farm is more
environmentally friendly
absolutely i know it's we're looking you
know part of our ethos is looking at
what we can do for nature
and and by definition when we're doing
things for naturals it's doing things
for the climate but but sort of
importantly we are a business as well
so what we're trying to do is is also
make our
business not more financially
sustainable
moving forward well yes and the
government says that it's got
ambitious and far-reaching sets of
investments they say
they've got plans that are designed to
incentivize sustainable farming
practices but
do you think the more that could be done
what kind of help could you do with
well you know we we have a lot of talk
about it and i suppose
the key is going to be seeing the action
over the next sort of two to three years
as we go through this
transition as we sort of leave behind
the european system of
farm support that we've had since 19th
the 1970s
and move into a payment for public goods
support system
um that is making all the right noises
to help us do that
but like i say it's it's going to be the
action on the ground in terms of
both the both the financial but also the
sort of cultural
change that hopefully we can eat in bed
and do
do you agree that farmers could do more
there's no point sort of
um denying that um we
you know we work within a certain
environment i think we we live with that
we
we live with climate change more than
anybody else you know where
my business is um is impacted by the
weather and ultimately the climate
um every every year it's very
stereotyping but that's
probably one of the main things we talk
about so but yeah there is there is more
that we can do
wait we're on a journey um i think we're
at the start of what could be quite an
exciting journey in terms of
the measures to to tackle both climate
change and
and nature recovery i think when we talk
about climate change we've really got to
talk about this recovery as well
because there's a huge task ahead in
terms of that
fraser hugo good to talk to you thank
you
thank you the watamu marine national
park on
kenya's coast is home to more than 600
species of fish
and seven species of turtle but
increasing tourism
high unemployment and a surge in illegal
fishing
are putting them at risk now one man's
efforts to help communities manage the
ecosystem more sustainably
has been rewarded with a prestigious
international prize
we'll hear from sami safari shortly but
first here's why he's saving
africa's sea turtles
five of the seven different species of
sea turtle
can be found along the kenyan coast
under threat from bycatch and poachers
who illegally sell them for meat and oil
sammy has worked tirelessly to convince
fishers to stop
taking turtles turning
poachers into protectors
and sami safari joins me now from the
watamu marine
national park summit safari huge
congratulations to you
tell us more about how your project
works
so uh so i am sami safari i work for
local austrian conservation in guatemala
kenya that's the kenyan coast
i lead an anti-poaching team and i
am also in the community development
team
so in general i do work so closely with
the fishers community
and in the futures community i do
education and awareness
talking to members of the local
community the importance of
nature and everything
so and the whole marine ecosystem
why is it so important to you to do this
work and to protect the marine ecosystem
it's really good for me to to do all
this work because
it hurts us have a resource
that will be
beneficial for the present and the
future generation
sami how are you going to spend your
winnings with the weekly fund
this is mainly to support
conservationists
working so closely with
local communities from the grassroots
to benefit wildlife and inhabitants
and even people so
with my funding or the word
i've already uh i got from a weekly
which i'm
really really thankful i'll use this one
to
improve governancy i'll also use it
to increase conservation and
biodiversity
reduce illegal poaching of both
fauna and the floor last but not least
financial management and monitoring
in community groups sami safari thanks
very much indeed
and that's everything from us for today
coming up tomorrow how
cornwall could hold the key to the uk's
green energy future thanks for watching
see you then